you know see you man thanks for making
me to see you thanks for having me
alright so call of duty modern warfare
you're on brand and this is call of duty
modern warfare but it's a reimagine
modern warfare exactly that is the exact
term we used at Infinity Ward is that it
is a reimagining of the modern warfare
franchise so it's still modern warfare
through and through complete with some
familiar characters as well but the
overall narrative and the single-player
storyline are completely new and fresh
and updated to be relevant and fit in a
present-day ok you guys had the
multiplayer reveal a couple of weeks ago
lots of news around that tell us what's
the focus of mp44 MW this year so first
of all we were just blown away by the
reaction from the fans and the players
our overall goal this year for MP was to
create the ultimate multiplayer
playground so we've got all sorts of
shapes and sizes of experiences we've
got our smaller tighter fast infinite to
two maps we've got a more traditional
6v6 maps and we've also got experiences
on our larger scale maps they're gonna
support upwards of a hundred players Wow
ok and you're also doing cross play as
well right yes we are indeed so we've
actually had a lot of questions from the
community about how cross play works in
a nutshell you'll be able to play
console to console and console to PC so
if you're partying it up on console and
you have a friend and PC that you want
to play with you guys can play together
oh wow ok so across everything it's all
gonna work absolutely
you also had a fun mode that I got to
play back in May at the studio 2v2 gun
fight which is like tell us a bit about
but it's like a ton us right
it is the fast-paced it is a ton of fun
it's fast its frenetic I actually heard
you did pretty well over there we had a
fun time me and Annie McNamara from Game
Informer talked about some other drugs I
think we compete against some of the
courage of those guys but those guys are
real Slayers though that's gonna say you
held your own yeah it was it was a fun
mode and I understand that you guys are
gonna be we know what you're doing a
beta in September bus we are and I hear
there might be something before that
absolutely so first of all if you're
here and happen to be at the show you
will be able to play Modern Warfare it's
on the show floor check it out at the
PlayStation booth ok
and so in preparation for our beta where
we get to be able to collect a lot of
feedback from the fans as well as test
cross-play we're doing an early test and
we've partnered with Playstation to have
an open to v2 alpha that's gonna start
this Friday August 23rd okay
this Friday August 23rd and that's
worldwide on PlayStation 4 yes it is
okay we will check it out call of duty
modern warfare alpha and I understand we
got a little sneak peek of it right
absolutely I brought a trailer along
with me so that people can see what's
coming up all right see all the maps
everything in the Alpha thanks so much
do you know thank you very much oh the
modern warfare
[Music]
[Music]
play V alpha a